The answer is, you can't assign an object of a class to a variable of an
interface type the object's class does not implement. We've seen that it's
possible to assign an object of a class to a variable of an interface type. And
this declaration isn't trying to assign a value of an interface type to a
variable of a class type. We can create a rectangle without too much trouble,
but rectangle doesn't implement drawable. So we can't store the rectangle that
we created in a variable of type drawable. This is a little bit weird, since
the rectangle actually does have a draw method, and the drawable interface
promises that it will have a draw method and nothing else. The problem is that
rectangle doesn't say that it implements drawable. For all Java knows, these
two drawable methods could be completely different. If we wanted to save a
rectangle in a drawable variable, we would need to change the rectangle class
to say that it implements drawable.